welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video for Star Wars the
Mandalorian Episode 2 hopefully you've
had a chance to see the first couple of
episodes by now the episode was crazy
short so if you thought something was
wrong and the episode was supposed to be longer no it was supposed to be just a
little over 30 minutes I'll address that
at the end of the video too but there
was a whole bunch of Easter eggs and we
finally got some answers about what's
going on with the baby if you're new to
the channel I'm doing videos for all the
mandalorian episodes be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm also
doing a Disney Plus giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
episode on the video obviously careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet will do top 10 and
easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 the title of the episode was
the child the episode was mostly
inspired by this old Japanese manga
called lone wolf and cub mixed with a
classic old western train heist talking
about the jobless sandcrawler
the story of that lone wolf and cub
manga is all about a person named Ogami
e - who's a former executioner for a
Shogun who's disgraced after some false
accusations by another clan he's forced
to take the path of an assassin but has
to take his son with him so he's like a
ronin samurai carrying this child around
him while he's going from job to job
just like the Mandalorian is forced to
go collect on this bounty through the
mud horn while bringing this child and
tote with him most of the actors at the
premiere said that they referred to this
little puppet as baby Yoda but Jon
Favreau and Dave Fulani were like don't
call it baby Yoda too much we're trying
to keep this secret so it was amazing
that they were able to keep that from
leaking from the set because for the
most part they did use a practical
little puppet and then just touched it
up with a little bit of CG but I loved
how expressive they made it using body
language because clearly it can't speak
with words yet but it can still
communicate with its body language and
even Master Yoda
during the prequels during the original
trilogy when he gets excited or when he
gets upset about something or he's sad
he expresses with his ear
so anytime something bad happens to the
mandalorian you see him get kind of
worried his ears will lower down a
little bit when he sits up and shows
that he is alive his ears pricked back
up when he gets really excited because
he finds something to eat the little
frog on the ground his ears prick up
again because he's really happy so even
though he's still a tiny baby
developmentally even by his own species
standards he demonstrates a deep
intuition about his surroundings and he
can sense what people are feeling
through the force he's powerful enough
that using the force to him is just like
breathing to us but number nine the
transduction attack he's attacked by
three Transocean bounty hunters at the
beginning of the episode on his way back
to the ship their only goal seems like
is to terminate baby Yoda one of them
almost gets it before he disintegrates
it with his rifle the weapons that they
attack him with the stun batons that are
on pole arms those are called vibro
weapons there are all kinds of different
vibro blades of different sizes they can
give up really strong electric blasts
they can vaporize people or they can
just be used to stun people but number 8
the problem of the Imperials is getting
worse he notices a brand new bounty
hunting tracking Bob on the three trand
oceans realizing Werner Herzog's
magistrate character is sending more and
more bounty hunters after baby Yoda and
it's only going to continue until he
delivers the baby to them and clearly
from the way this one charged baby Yoda
trying to end it they're not after it
to bring it back alive so that wasn't
clear when he was actually negotiating
his bounty for best gar and he says I
realized bounty hunting is a complicated
profession if anything were to happen to
it it's also very wink-wink acceptable
if you bring back proof of termination I
think some people saw that and they're
like no he wants it back alive no he
definitely wants it dead it's the doctor
that wants the baby back alive because
he seems like he's connected to the
cloning facility at camino from attack
of the clones so if he recognized this
symbol he has it on his sleeve that was
the sleeve on all the clones at the
Camino facility and attack of the clones
so that's why everyone's thinking that
this baby might be a clone of Master
Yoda so when people call it baby Yoda
technically it might not be incorrect
even though it's not the original Yoda
either way every baby of his species is
incredibly force sensitive so it
wouldn't really matter if it wasn't Yoda
it would still be crazy powerful which
becomes more clear when seven baby Yoda
tries to heal him using the force even
though he stops him twice it is kind of
funny to see how easily he's able to
escape that little baby carriage pod
like it's no big deal he just climbs
right out anytime he wants to him trying
to heal the mandalorian using the force
is a bit of a callback to obi-wan Kenobi
healing Luke after he'd been jumped by
the sand people in Star Wars Episode
four we learned later in the episode the
Mandalorians knowledge of force lore is
actually pretty weak he's still pretty
confused about what's going on with the
baby so it sounds like he didn't meet a
whole lot of Jedi during the Clone Wars
but remember from the flashbacks in
Episode one we know that that kid was
there during the Clone Wars
so he's at least heard tales of the Jedi
and then because of order 66 right after
what was happening here most of them
were ended so it makes sense that
he wouldn't have run into that many Jedi
during his lifetime but number 6 the
Jawas gut the razor crest huge
moment he vaporizes a few with his rifle
before they take off and they begin the
train heist portion of the episode
straight out of an old western it was
actually kind of funny to see them just
poof into clouds of ash when he
vaporized them to baby Yoda even seems
like he's enjoying it here like he looks
up at him like he's kind of excited by
what's happening oh wow we're going to go
on a bit of a trip here later in the
episode when they go to negotiate and he
admits to disintegrating a few of them
that's probably why they don't like me
that's a bit of a callback to Empire
Strikes Back when Darth Vader told Boba
Fett no disintegrations when they
captured Han Leia and Chewie bounty
hunters really like to disintegrate
people when they can number five the
sandcrawler train heist so as funny as
it was watching him go fold Donkey Kong
trying to climb that sandcrawler
while the job was her throwing stuff
down at him the whole time baby Yoda
following in the pod was even funnier he
seemed completely on board for whatever
they were doing no matter how dangerous
it seemed but just to explain how the
baby pod works they sort of explain
later in the episode - during the mud
horn fight it's slaved to his gauntlet
and is automatically set to follow him
wherever he goes
that's why later in the episode when
he's wrangling that giant horn bull
creature at the mud horn he waves his
gauntlet to dodge the pot away from it
it is just a standard baby pod there's
nothing really special about it
there were people after the ending of
episode 1 that wondered whether or not
baby Yoda
was levitating the pod using the force
orbit which is part of the technology of
the pot itself so this episode basically
answered that it's just built into the
tech of the pod it just hovers
everywhere it goes in the thing about
baby Yoda and this scene here - you can
clearly tell he's already attached to
the mandalorian he looks kind of worried
when he thinks that he might be dead
after he falls off the top of the
sandcrawler
but watch how he expresses when he sees
the Mandalorians sit up and sees that
he's alive when they go back to Nick
Nolte's ugh nog character for help
there's also a funny Empire Strikes Back
reference when baby Yoda eats the Frog
yes it's just a funny visual gag but
it's also a reference to Empire Strikes
Back when they were making that movie
there were people on the crew that
referred to Yoda as a swamp frog and
then on the DVD commentary for Star Wars
attack of the clones George Lucas joked
that Yoda was the illegitimate child of
Kermit the Frog and Miss Piggy so it's
just a joke about Yoda being a frog so
baby Yoda eats the Frog but number four
the negotiation the jaw was telling me
speaks their language so poorly he
sounds like a Wookiee which is another
reference to the Star Wars Holiday
Special in the scenes with Boba Fett and
Chewbacca there's an r5 droid behind
them that's similar to the r5 droid the
Jabba's tried to sell to the large in
Luke Skywalker then they tell him that
he needs to find the egg of a giant
creature called the mud horn which is
kind of a bullish version of the reek
creature from Star Wars Attack of the
Clones
we also finally get to see the inside of
the control room of a Jawa sandcrawler
with the Mandalorian bumping his head
just to give us a sense for the scale
baby Yoda also seems very excited to be
here to number three the Mandalorian
versus the mud horn they go for a little
bit of a jump scare when he's in the
cave and just pitch-black darkness in
that eye opens right in front of him he
gets his beaten, he almost
winds up dying it's a little bit like
an old western with a cowboy trying to
wrangle a giant bull but the real major moment here is number two baby Yoda using the
Force to own the mud horn just
levitating it up and it's a bit of a
reference to Yoda raising Luke
Skywalker's x-wing out of the swamp a
very size matters not type of lesson for
the Mandalorian even though he still
doesn't totally understand what's going
on with baby Yoda in the force you also
see during this - the baby Yoda seems
like it's really worried about the
Mandalorian and senses that he's in
trouble using the Force
remember even though he's still really
tiny he can still sense what other
people are feeling using the force the
reason why he passes out right after
doing it is because he's still
technically a very tiny baby even for
his species he's not old enough to even
formally begin Jedi training but that's
how powerful he is that he can do this
at that very young age they get the egg
the Jawas just start chomping down
apparently it's just a delicacy for them
and that's all they care about we just
want some sweets give us that sweet
sweet giant hairy egg but number one
returning baby Yoda to the Imperials to
collect on the bounty so they have this
montage to them putting the razor crest
back together is a very patchwork ship
which is just meant to show you how much
he cares about the ship like his
relationship with his ship is like Han
Solo's relationship with the Millennium
Falcon it might seem like a hunk of junk
to Luke Skywalker at first glance but to
Han Solo it's the most important woman
in his life for a good long while till
Leia comes along the funniest thing
about this scene too when they're
dragging the parts back if you look at
the side of the sled the job was even
stole his space toilet from the ship
which is just totally gross it's a
bummer that Nick Nolte's egg nog
character isn't going to be with him in the
next couple of episodes maybe he'll come
back again later this season maybe he'll
come back during season two from all the
trailer footage they were hyping up it
seemed like he would be a bigger
character during the series because he's
got a full set of best scar Armour in
the trailers and Werner Herzog is
talking about filming scenes with baby
Yoda at the premiere last week I'm
assuming that he collects on the bounty
but it's clearly not the end of his
relationship with baby Yoda and his
importance in the story is just the
beginning also addressing the short
length of episodes I actually thought
that something was wrong because when we
got to this part of the episode I
checked to see how much time was left
and there was only a couple minutes left
in the episode so I'm assuming the
reason why episodes have been so short
is because one they're super expensive
to make they spent about a hundred and
fifty million dollars making all eight
of the episodes but the other reason was
also probably because they weren't sure
what season 1 was going to be and they
made it in a vacuum without any test
screenings or anything like that so they
might be correcting that for season 2
just because the response has been so
strong so far but I don't know how long
the future episodes are going to be
we'll probably find out about that in
the next couple of weeks but here's a
schedule update for all the rest of the
episodes it'll be a Friday show
the episodes are released a little after
midnight but my videos typically won't
post till midday so plenty of time to
watch let me know if there's any big
Easter eggs that you saw in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video I've
got some new Rick and Morty season 4 and
some new Marvel that I'll be posting
really soon congratulations Nick papel
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Mandalorian video please email me on
the about page my channel so I can get
your contact details
everyone click here for the mandalorian
episode 1 video and click here for my
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching. I have spoken.